if I were to ask you what the most
important advancement humankind has ever
made
what would you say money would make the
case for fire our species was in an
evolutionary rut until we harnessed its
power it gave us the warp to survive
harsh winters it's light extended or day
its destructive powers gave us a weapon
against predators and it allowed us to
cook her food which allowed our brains
to grow our discovery of fire
transformed not only our technologies
but our culture and our way of life but
I would argue that we are currently
living in a time of equal or even
greater change we are living in a time
of incredible growth one that has
already started to transform the way we
live our lives the age of information
with 40% of the world's population
currently connected to the Internet the
human race is more intertwined than ever
before but what led to this amazing tool
what single invention gave rise to our
smartphone equipped generation the
transistor the transistor is information
itself even this video is just a series
of ones and zeroes beaming across the
planet to be interpreted by the
processors in your computers without the
transistor I wouldn't have access to the
wealth of information online to do my
research I wouldn't be able to use my
animation software to make these videos
and I certainly wouldn't be able to
share it here for the world to see the
transistor is so simple but it is the
foundation of all our modern computers
to understand its impact we need to
understand the history in science behind
us before the transistor existed we used
vacuum tubes which are these bulky
evacuated glass bulbs the triode vacuum
tube consisted of three parts the
cathode grid and anode the current is
passed through the cathode and it begins
to heat up causing it to release
electrons as gases have been removed
from the tube the electrons have very
little resistance to their movement and
they are attracted to the positively
charged anode this completes the circuit
and a current flows but we can
manipulate this flow of electrons in
many useful ways with the grid for
example we can use it as a switch if we
place a light bulb here it will only
light up when there's a positive voltage
across the grid if we apply a negative
voltage the negative charge will repel
electrons trying to pass through this is
the foundation of binary coding which is
the ones and zeros that gave birth to
the age of information here one is a
positive voltage and zeros are negative
one turns the light on zero turns it off
the world's first general-purpose
electronic computer the ENIAC used
18,000
vacuum tubes to perform calculations
designed by john mauchly and jay presper
eckert
it was completed in 1945 it was
purpose-built to calculate trajectories
for artillery during World War two a
calculation that would take a human a
day to calculate took ENIAC 30 minutes
but this thing weighed 30 tons and took
up an entire room it was incredibly
power hungry as the vacuum tube cathodes
needed to be heated to work which also
meant that the vacuum tubes burnt out
regularly and needed to be replaced all
this to perform a function that your
phone basically does with Angry Birds
today it's computing power could be
contained on a silicon chip no larger
than a grain of sand that's thanks to
the transistor a modern foam has around
2 billion transistors which performed
the exact same job as the vacuum tube
but on the nano scale let's look at how
it works many of you will recognize the
transistor is one of these but this is a
true hole transistor that you can buy
from hobby electronics stores for your
DIY projects the transistor is in your
CPU or microscopic and are manufactured
with incredible precision with machines
on thin wafers of silicon crystals that
are sliced off silicon ingots like this
so what makes silicon so special that an
entire section of the San Francisco Bay
Area has been nicknamed after the
material silicon is a semiconductor
which means it's conducting properties
can be tailored by introducing
impurities to the crystal structure
silicon has four electrons in its
valence shell and this is the outermost
orbit for electrons and it determines
many of the chemical properties of the
atom atoms want eight electrons in that
shell as this makes them very stable so
silicon readily forms covalent bonds
with four neighboring silicon atoms to
gain those extra electrons now if we
introduce those impurities to this pure
silicon crystal we can change how it
conducts the current if we add
phosphorus which has five electrons in
its valence shell the extra electron is
left free to roam the crystal structure
this extra electron makes the n-type
negatively charged which is where the
name comes from the p-type is positively
charged because it is doped with boron
which has three electrons in its valence
shell this structure wants to gain its
final electron and will steal electrons
from its neighboring atoms this creates
a mobile positive charge called a hole
the conductivity of the material has
thus been increased as we've increased
the number of mobile charges when we
arrange n-type and p-type semiconductors
like this and attach terminals to each
we create the world's most prevalent
transistor the NPN transistor the
transistor works due to the interaction
of those free electrons and holes at the
end
and p-type Junction free electrons in
the n-type were migrated over to fill
those holes in the p-type this creates a
boundary layer called the depletion
layer which prevents more electrons
passing through due to the negative
charges repelling each other
but when a positive voltage is applied
to the base it negates the depletion
layer and allows current to flow through
completing the circuit as you can see
this is very similar to the function of
the vacuum tube so how exactly does this
allow computers to perform all these
complex functions that we see today
let's look at a very basic example let's
add two numbers together first we need
to learn how numbers are represented in
binary that's the ones and zeros that
are used to sort data this is the number
15 which is the largest number you can
represent with 4 bits the first bit
represents 1 the next 2 then 4 and
finally 8 added up that equals 15 this
pattern continues with each successive
bit representing double the previous so
we can add an additional bit if we want
to count up to 31 let's add 5 and 6
together to do this we want the circuit
that will hold a 1 in this position when
either r1 and carry the 1 forward when
both are 1 as you can see this will give
us the number 11 the simplest circuit
that can do this is a half adder which
contains two types of logic gates these
are devices that can modify the binary
code they are built using transistors
the first is the xor logic gate which
gives a 1 only when one of the inputs is
1 if both are 0 or 1 it gives a 0 the
second logic gate is a none gate which
gives a 0 for everything except when
both inputs are 1 if we worried these
logic gates like this we create a half
adder which gives two outputs our sum
and our carry this allows us to add our
binary number one bit at a time a more
complicated circuit is needed to perform
the calculation in one step modern
computers can perform millions of these
calculations per second and they're
still getting faster the co-founder of
Intel gordon amor noticed a trend in
1965 that the density of transistors on
integrated circuits doubles every two
years that trend has held until very
recently but it is starting to slow down
one of the reasons for this is the less
well-known of Moore's predictions Moore
second law or rocks law which states
that the cost of manufacturing these
devices will double every four years
Intel made an announcement last year
that the rate of advancement was slowing
for these reasons it's getting more and
more difficult for chip manufacturers to
shrink their product while maintaining
profit
another problem that transistors are
facing is quantum tunneling as these
transistors get smaller so do the
barriers between different sections the
barriers between each section of the
transistor are getting so thin that
electrons can pass right through them
with no definitive successor to the
silicon transistor lined up this
incredible period of growth over the
last 50 years could patrol in the near
future some want to harness quantum
mechanics to perform calculations faster
than any transistor ever could others
want to decentralize computing power and
create the so-called Internet of Things
Intel have said themselves that they
plan to shift their focus from increases
in speed to decrease in power
consumption
one thing is for sure the computer
industry will have to redefine itself in
the near future thanks for watching
thanks here incredible response to their
last sponsorship the great courses Plus
have sponsored me once again so thank
you to all my subscribers patreon
supporters and the great courses plus
for helping real engineering exist if
you enjoy my videos you'll definitely
like the great courses plus they have
over 7000 different lectures from
world-renowned educators they have a
huge range of topics if you'd like to
learn more about electronics they even
have a course for that or you can learn
about photography chess and cooking
these courses give you an in-depth
knowledge of a variety of subjects while
allowing you to learn at your own pace
without test your exams you can get a
free 1:1 trial by going to the gray
courses plus com ford slash real
engineering if you'd like to see more
content or support real engineering the
links from my patreon Instagram Facebook
and Twitter accounts are below